well joining me now is the former Royal
bodyguard to Queen Elizabeth II Simon
Morgan Princess Diana's former Butler
Paul Barrow and a Fox News contributor a
New York Post columnist Miranda Devine
well welcome to all of you uh Miranda
let me start with you across the pond
there you and I know Manhattan very well
we've got a lot of Yellow Cabs in our
time does any of this version of events
from The sussex's Ring true to you
no and if they've just chosen the wrong
place to try and pull this stunt because
there are so many cameras in New York
there are so many celebrities much more
important than they are and the carry-on
just fell flat everybody knew that it
was bogus and it's obvious why they did
it they created the drama they drove
around Manhattan for an hour and a half
to to create some sort of event that
Harry was filming on his phone
um presumably for the next Netflix
installment and uh and now they're on
the front page no one even cared about
Meghan Markle getting some award it
would have been sort of the bottom of
page six now they're on the front page
which is what they wanted and all I can
say is life in Montecito must be
incredibly boring
completely well it is incredibly boring
we know that from the Netflix
documentary if it is they basically walk
around with a bunch of chickens and go
and see Oprah Winfrey every 10 minutes
um all right let me bring in Simon
Morgan you've been a bodyguard to the
late great Queen you've seen a lot of
Paparazzi in your time the rules here
are much tighter in the UK particularly
since the death of Princess Diana and
quite rightly so this couldn't have
happened there but in New York you know
it's an epicenter of celebrity culture
in America I've been around a lot of big
stars New York where this kind of thing
has gone on it goes with the territory
absolutely it does it's part as as your
security detail that's going to be part
of your plan you you accept you're going
to have interaction with the press and
you're going to look at that what is
your mitigation and what are your
contingencies if you want a 10-minute
Journey Simon right this is literally a
10 minute Journey 57th Street to mid 70s
we think it was an upper east side to a
friend's house if that was the journey
how could it possibly extend a two hours
I mean that's the worrying Factor
because you know you are you are on the
move you're out in the public domain if
it's a 10-minute Journey why let's not
make it a 10 minute Journey that's the
that's the worrying bit as you're going
around and around and if you don't want
the paparazzi to know where you're going
then don't go to a friend's house in New
York when you're leaving a massive media
event with 100 Paparazzi outside I mean
it's completely insane unless they were
doing this deliberately again that seems
to be the Crux of it they didn't want to
show out where they were staying and
that's caused part of the problem but
the cat and mouse game with the
paparazzi we you know back in 2008 2009
you know that's a that's a game you're
not going to win and we realized that at
royalty protection
when they the security decided to put
them into a Yellow Cab I mean Yellow
Cabs are in New York are notorious for
being a Pretty Reckless and they speed a
lot
um but you don't know who the hell it is
right and you're putting in some two of
the most famous people in the world into
the first Yellow Cab you see with any
security raw protection guy do that uh
no no as simple as that because
Unthinkable right that key part that
security driving piece is actually a key
part of your protection detail now
you've put them in a a yellow cab with
something that you don't know and as a
security professional your response to
conflict comes in through phases fight
flight or freeze freeze is removed from
you because of the training and then you
have two options fight or flight and but
what is that man going to do in that
situation he's had no formalized
training in that role and he could be
like a rabbit caught in headlamps or he
could fight when we won a flight or vice
versa that is the weakness of that
particular decision okay Paul Burrell
you've been waiting patiently you you
obviously Princess Diana and the boys
extremely well
um that Harry is trying again to use
what happened to his mother as
justification for his you know in my
view very over emotional in this case uh
over egging of the of the paparazzi
souffle saying look this was close to
death near catastrophe blah blah what do
you feel when he invokes what happened
to his mother in that Paris underpass do
you understand it or do you think he's
doing this too much
I think it's too much because
um I think this drama unfolding on the
other side of the Atlantic is to make
them more relevant again is to bring
them back into the public Spotlight and
as our dear Lake Queen said our
Recollections may vary as you said in
your intro that's that's obviously
what's happening here
um to make any comparison with a car
chase in Paris which took the princess's
life and one in Manhattan
um is really very sad it's very sad
wrong and distasteful
um they are totally two totally
different circumstances the princess was
actually
um avoiding the media as much as she
could could possibly avoid the media on
that night and in the reverse Megan and
Harry were courting it and so there are
two different circumstances here nothing
nothing is is similar other than
photographs being taken
um I think it's very distasteful there's
clearly an incident
it's been blown out of all well it's an
incident it's an incident which the
police said let led to no a collision no
arrests right and as far as they could
say you could tell by the language they
use they just don't think this was a big
deal at all Miranda let me ask you about
just generally about Megan and her
they've obviously made their American
bed and now have to lie on it it's been
a very lucrative bed but they've torched
their families all their families pretty
much apart from Megan's mother is now
out of the picture
um they don't seem very happy for people
who were seeking happiness but what is
the American reaction to them now I mean
it seems to me that more and more
they're becoming a bit of a laughing
stock
yes yeah utter contempt and uh just sort
of amusement about why they're carrying
on like this it's not as if they are you
know the biggest celebrities that have
ever come to New York and
um the South Park episode uh really
encapsulated it you know they're on this
worldwide privacy tour running around
trying to get people's attention while
saying give me my privacy and I think it
it you know it stems from Meghan
markle's
um complete uh fascination with Fame and
narcissism she loves the paparazzi she
loves the cameras and that's just
the opposite of what Harry wants Harry
is
um you know deeply wounded by what
happened to his mother and he's got into
his head that the paparazzi that he sees
around him uh his mother's murderers and
so Meghan Markle has exploited that uh
that's her secret power to control Harry
is to exploit his deepest darkest fear
he couldn't save his mother and maybe he
can't save his wife yeah I mean I think
there may be some truth to that Paul
Burrell what would what would Dinah have
made it what would she say to him if she
was still with us Diner what would she
say about the way Harry has taken his
life and and what he's been doing to his
family
you know Pierce you knew the princesses
as well and you know that she would say
to Harry Harry you you should be uh I
applaud you for marrying for love I
applaud you for looking after your
family but you don't have to you have to
abide by the rules and Harry's rule was
always to stand by his brother and to
protect him and she would be appalled
she would be absolutely appalled by this
mess that's going on at the moment Harry
seems to be a victim he seems to be a a
a a passenger on this train and it's
going to end in tears and we all know
it's going to end in tears and I don't
want to see his heart broke again I saw
it once before and I don't want to see
that happen to him I still love him he's
Diana's boy and you know what can we do
to try to save him I'm not sure that he
can save himself no I think that's sadly
that may be the case Simon finally
he's got this cult battle here over
whether he should be allowed Royal
protection if you were still working
there would you think that that's
Justified that he should get that or
should the British taxpayer be paying
for that it's extremely difficult
everything has to be done on threat and
risk and that's one of the decisions
that was made around that as well as the
role within the family but I think when
you go down the route of police
protection being sold to the highest
bidder I think that is a problem and one
of the main problems is there's simply
not enough protection officers right so
therefore the people that would need it
wouldn't necessarily get it because now
they've been sold to the highest bidder
yeah listen thank you all what a great
panel uh Miranda Paul Sam thank you very
much all three of you very much indeed